hey guys my name is Sally this is going
to be my first solo trailer reaction I'm
really excited about this one and
especially it being my first because I'm
a huge fan of Johnny Depp lately he's
been doing films that don't necessarily
seem like the old Johnny Depp we used to
know it just kind of seems like the
cartoony Johnny Depp that became after
Jack Sparrow and I'm really excited
because this one is transcendence and it
just sounds really cool so I'm going to
react to the trailer so you can react
with me and here we go please welcome my
partner in science and in life dr. will
caster the path to fill their super
intelligence requires us to unlock the
most fundamental secrets of the universe
universe there it is imagine a nashim
with a full range of human emotion its
analytical power
will be greater than the collective
intelligence of every person in the
history of the world some scientists
refer to this as the singularity
professor I call it transcendence
a series of attacks conducted by a
radical anti-tech group known as rift
they hit AI labs all over the country we
lost decades of research and development
Morgan Freeman really the bullet must
have been laced with it the effect is
irreversible wills body is dying but his
mind is a pattern of electrical signals
we can upload his consciousness we can
save him not like this it did not
assuming that this works if we missed
anything I thought childhood memory how
will you know who you're dealing with
he's not dead holder Nicola oh my god I
can't feel anything over here you need
to get me online I need more power it
may be intelligent may even be sent him
this is no mouth shut it down shut down
that he then shove it down he's like
shove it down we don't know the danger
this is astounding so how do we fight it
good god and they I is like any
intelligence it has needs the real will
die
it'll start to evolve where's the
machine to them cause
perhaps the entire world where are you
going
everywhere
I am so confused what transcended okay
I'm really confused I guess they did
that on purpose so that you'd watch the
movie but have some good actors in it
and can't go wrong with morgan freeman
like ever especially the lego movie that
was great so thank you guys for watching
go ahead and check out my channel it's
salamander Sally I know I don't have
much up on that channel yet but I will
I'm planning to come out with a
Valentine's date video which I'm filming
tomorrow yeah whatever also just you
know sub to this channel cuz it's great
and the boys are great and funny and
can't go wrong with boys and being funny
unless they make fun of women's yeah I
hope you enjoyed it there's more coming
yeah